each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
yeah so and Georgia is leading the
project called I cub and which became
the foundation of the European project
called the robotic up and he were to ask
more about it yeah microphone so so hi
everybody thanks for being here the as
saying he was saying I'm from general in
Italy from this new institute called the
Italian Institute technologies very new
was started only three years ago but
Italian government to try to promote
research and also try to foster some
more straight collaboration of
researchers win industry although what
I'm going to show today is pretty much
from the research side we're also from a
department that is called a robotics
playing cognitive science which so
includes I mean these three keywords are
all represented in the department we
have neurophysiologists and people doing
psychophysics and we sitting next to
each other so there are a lot of
cross-disciplinary projects here and in
particular I'm going to talk about let's
say my favorite or our flagship project
that is called rubber cap this is funded
by the European Union does in the
European Union there's a section the
works and cognitive systems and
different projects and they've been
investing quite a lot recently like half
a billion in the last five years so
quite noticeable investment in that in
that direction this is the place in the
mountains next to Genoa in Italy and
yeah that's it for telling about where I
come from they you know about my
background
so our main focus it's on the
implementation of biological sound
models of cognition but these I mean
trying to learn from biology transfer
into models and eventually implement
them into real robots so we're trying to
collaborate for the first part we're
trying to collaborate within your
physiology and psychophysics people and
I'm sort of leading heading group of
people there have been working on
developing robots and implementing these
models into the robots and with the goal
eventual goal of building robot
controllers they can learn and adapt be
more flexible thanks to you eventually
meh no need to program explicitly but
you can just demonstrate tasks of course
there's one long term goal take awhile
to get there and I would like to do this
by as a saber sort of reverse
engineering go and look at the
biological systems at the brain and get
information for that building models
this can be in the form of mathematical
or control theory models and eventually
put all these in a full functioning
robot and I mean it's quite a long way
to get there but we have pieces and bits
that we now ready sort of to put
together so I'll show today a few
experiments that are not on the robot by
our own separate sets of data and this
sort of illustrates the model we're
thinking about and I'll show you also
something that has been done on the
robot and what we mean by a robot
demeanor it's a full humanoid and again
these two things will eventually
converge but it not there yet the
colonel of the problem for us or what
we're trying to understand about the
brain is whether we can mimic the brain
by just playing programming that will be
the picture on the left or rather we
need to grow a
by implementing suitable learning
mechanisms into a robot and let the
property interact with the environment I
guess we're more on the second on the
right side of these although there's
quite a lot of programming still in the
in what we do and the robot we're
building a guiding philosophy in this
aspect is that cognition cannot probably
be hand coded into the robot it has to
be the problem the product of the
process of development and there's a
particular view on cognition the makes
it are almost identical to prediction so
and I'll show few examples coming from
biological sciences that show these
aspects in in at work this is a little
video that I actually shows a prediction
in very young infants these six month
old infant reaching for a little toy so
the toy is moving constant velocity and
you see is nicely goes and grabs it and
you see now a different situation the
toy stops and the this again so reaching
is perfect at this age but if you
suddenly stop the movement the reaching
where the hand goes where to the
predicted position of the object if you
had not stopped and this basically shows
that since they're almost very beginning
you have a prediction component a
predictive component in place and that's
required for interacting with the
environment you cannot live without
without that and I mean this has been
pioneered than the slaughter research by
this person class phone Austin which is
was part of our project Robocop there
are other experiments they show similar
things this one that I like just because
it the setup is so weird it's basically
a rotating room and they sit a person
inside the rotating room and then they
try reach
and of course since the room with
rotating this there are Coriolis forces
and the trajectory is deviated from the
straight path so you see here in the
plot like the solid line there is the
pre rotation that is that means the room
is stationary at that point and if you
ask to reach you do the perfect straight
patridge that's typical of human human
reach they go along a straight path now
as the room starts rotating you see a
deviation from the trajectory but nicely
if you waited long enough and the long
enough is not so long is only 30 40
trials the brain adapts and goes back to
the straight trajectories so the brain
really lost straight trajectories now
you should stop the room you see an
aftereffect so the error goes on the
other way now the point here is that
there are two strategies to compensate
for disturbances one is stiffening your
muscles and you can actually do it so
one possibility here is that you were
actually stiffening your muscles and
this means that you contract so your
flexors and extensors are both
contracted and you do the trajectory and
if there is a disturbance you stiff so
you remain on tract and this could be a
valid strategy if not for the after
effect that you see there which means
that in practice you're not contracting
you're just modeling the disturbances
again you have a model and you're
building a model on the fly the brain is
doing that all the time and using this
model to to compensated disturbances and
it's the same in other situations this
is another experiment where this person
is moving in an object on a given
trajectory and on the beam measuring the
grip force and they were calculating the
load for the load force will be due to
gravity the grip force they can put
sensors and measure how much force has
been exerted by the hand in the next
point here on on these this experiment
is that load forcing grip force are
exactly synchronous
as soon as you move from this
configuration to this configuration you
increase your you increase your grip
force now the fact they're synchronous
tells us something about the brain and
that in fact the brain is building a
model again it's not just waiting for
slippage to occur to measure it and then
then to steer to increase the grip force
that's not the case because if you if
the brain were doing that you many
objects will fall from your hands what
you see here the two things are
synchronous which means that this
prediction the brain takes time
sucessful information takes time from to
go from the tactile sensors to the brain
and back I mean the fastest spinal
reflex are in their order 30 to 50
milliseconds so you don't see the
milliseconds there which means there's
no there's no delay which means the
brain is actually predicting what the
load forces will be and generating them
a compensation in in advance I mean this
is an adult person so he knows how to
move an object from one place to another
so the yep not for that particular
object but there's one thing about human
touches that as soon as you touch an
object you can estimate the friction
just the deformation on your fingertips
is enough to start estimating friction
so you basically know how much force to
apply so okay so this is the first part
of our view on cognition saying that the
brain has to build models and use these
models to behave effectively another
thing that is important to know about
these models is that there's quite a lot
of motor information involved in these
models they not only or purely
perceptual and this is the old strain or
research that goes back to the worker
rizzolatti is this neurophysiologist and
working quite
for quite some time on the monkey mostly
in but also on humans and the reason I'm
showing this sketch the brain is to show
that to couple of things first of all
that these people been analyzing a
region called f5 that is this one here
and this is this called the premotor
premotor cortex and the reason I mean
I'll tell you be more about the
responses of these neurons they found
and to know why this would be surprising
so the people these guys in particular
started looking at neurons in that area
and they start to find the things like
these these are grasping us what we see
here are a single neural recording so
they basically put an electrode close
enough to a neuron they start seeing
action potentials each dot in the those
diagrams is an action potential record
multiple experiments they synchronize
them and that what you see that there is
the histogram the cumulative histogram
of the activation of the neuron now the
point here is the following deserve a
promoter area and f5 is specifically
connected to manipulation and the
starting seeing things like these so
there's a for instance they recording a
particular neuron here are unit one or
eight dash three and the monkey was
reaching and grasping an object what you
see here is that doesn't matter what
hand is being used the neuron will still
fire which means that is not coding for
the movement process coding for more
abstract action so it doesn't matter
which muscles are eventually getting
activated this is a newer on that
encodes grasping and also encodes
grasping of a particular type so in this
particular case it encodes grasping a
precision grip drafting with two fingers
but doesn't encode something like a full
pawn a cylindrical grass grass type so
it seems and they found
hundreds of these neurons and it seems
that desire 85 as a sort of a vocabulary
of actions the very abstract in the
sense that some of them fire whether the
monkey use the left the left hand the
right hand or the mouth so that's also a
grasping is valid grasping so the monkey
just put something in the mouth the same
neuron will will be activated as if
grasping as a concept as being extracted
at this level but okay this is a purely
motor response but they start to finding
other things in this was more surprising
so this happened 20 years ago and maybe
round up maybe 25 but around that time
there was this idea of the brain as okay
here in the occipital lobe you have
vision then something in between some
coordinate conversion system more here
found out you have the motor cortex
that's where you know you control your
muscles and that's it I mean vision here
motor control there and something in
between the connects and transforms the
data but then they started looking at
these neurons in again in f5 and the fun
surprising so practically the fun visual
responses and this is a particular
neuron the response when the monkey for
instance is reaching for an object like
a ring or when it's also just watching
the object which what you see there so
it's like as soon as the monkey sees the
object this neuron gets activated if the
monkey decides to reach for the object
sender on will continue to fire so it's
sort of representing some feature of
that object that is required for
grasping it and if you change the object
of response changes as well so a
cylinder will an activate this object
there's neuron but maybe if you take
another neuron a cylinder will be the
best the best stimulus for that
particular neuron so this to say that
the view of the brain of 25 years ago
was a bit wrong so there's no this
vision part motor part but the brain is
sort of mixing up signals all the way
from vision to motor control so it's all
a big big interconnected Network and
it's difficult to disentangle specific
visual responsive neurons with respect
to motor control and these guys are very
famous for finding these other class of
neurons also in zaria f5 which are
called mirror neurons and you may heard
of them what happened here is that the
fund that some of these neurons will
respond is into again in two situations
one where the monkey is just reaching
grasping an object but also same neuron
same unit when the experimenter the
person is reaching and grasping the same
object and these neurons are very
selective so they've been doing a lot of
things like using tools to grasp the
object instead of hand and the neuron
will stay silent or they try hiding the
object behind the screen so showing the
monkey the object putting screen in
between and then reaching behind the
screen and the neuron will fire in
prediction of the type of grasp they
will be appropriate for that object this
is just to tell that is not merely the
interpretation of visual information
it's also a model or a prediction of
what the monkey will expect or that
particular action in that particular
situation and the went forward the fund
other neurons in again mirror neurons in
different area in this is interesting
because here even the motor Act doesn't
change though because of the context the
neuron will may change the response and
i'll tell you the experiment here what
was happening was that there were two
situations basically the monkey was
given a piece of food co-leader put on a
tray there was sitting on the table as
shown there or eat it so if the tray was
visible
the food will have to go on the tray if
the tray wasn't visible the food where
the monkey was free to eat the food and
the phone neurons that respond in this
situation the striking part of these is
that the momentum monkey starts reaching
the neurons start firing and but the
point is that there's no there's no clue
at that I mean the trade is there so you
can think that's the clue but the action
itself is still the same the motor
information connected to that action
doesn't code for the different
situations what happens here is that of
course the presence of different objects
may buy us the firing of these neurons
towards one possibility or the other
it's like this newer and sort of coding
more some more intentional level of the
monkey in the sense that all these other
visual information is taken to account
to decide what action has to be taken
and this is true also if the monkey is
just observing a person doing the same
the same type of actions and again from
the kinematics of the first street you
cannot tell the difference so this is
just to show that it's a bit more
complicated than just purely looking at
motor information so move to a slightly
different experiment but just to show
that the I mean this idea of
manipulating things connects to more
high level functions in the brain and in
particular desire f5 by the way is what
is known in the human brain as Broca's
area and Broca's area is connected
speech people that have damage in the
area cannot speak well they lose the
ability to speak although depending on
the damage you get different different
effects broadcast is more on the
production phonological level so they
start lacking the ability to properly
articulate words so a group again
rizzolatti a group of other people
started doing experiments in this
direction
with with peach and in particular with
Patriot to do that with people and the
technique they use is called TMS the
stands for transcranial magnetic
stimulation just place a coil close to
the brain the SOB produces a strong
magnetic field that disturbs the brain
induces a current a current that
disturbs makes all the neurons in the
mode region to fire which means
effectively that that area is it snow
able to do anything coherently for a
hundred milliseconds you can then do
various things a particular experiments
these guys have been doing was to sit a
person on a chair present a set of words
by speaking them measure the response in
the tank muscle and do the TMS at the
same time the response in the
thomasville is basically showing whether
there's a connection between listening
to the words the stimulation and the
activation of the tone muscles typically
when you seems like when you listen to
words you're sort of your muscles are
pre activated to say say the same things
you listening to although without TMS
you don't see the effect i mean there's
any inhibition somewhere the blocks the
movement or your your tongue with the
TMS you basically see this effect and
you can measure it so the words they
presented we're Italian words because
these people are from Italy in
particular there were two classes words
and pseudo words and also the phonemes
involved we're different so this one
case where there's a double r and that
sounds a bit like birra the first word
there so we rolling R which is beer and
and you see all the other words there
the pseudo words are perfectly
pronounceable in Italian but they don't
have any meaning the same thing for for
the double F now that the
to type the two phonemes show basically
have a different involvement in the
tongue movement so double f you don't
need to move the tank match commercially
you have to move the time for doing the
double r and this is the result which is
basically that you listen into words
again TMS the Double R so you see it a
different involvement due to the DMS
when you do the double r vs. double F
which means that you basically listening
to these words any you see in system
measuring and the tongue muscle only
when you listen to the double F there's
no activation of the tongue muscle
because that's not required for
pronouncing double F when you listen in
to the Double R there's a dis activation
that you revealed through the TMS
because you will move the tongue to say
a double r and for the pseudo words
there's a different significant effect
so it's not it's not only the phoneme
that counts but it's also the meaning of
the word apparently from from this
experiment and there was a control made
of just sounds that sort of mimic the
porosity of the world but they don't
have any any phonetic content and see
that as again a different significant
response in that case so this is to say
that your motor cortex is sort of
involved also in your speech perception
and I mean this again some is sort of a
new result for neurophysiology although
there were people saying similar things
in the past just I mean the first
evidence that this is the case has been
done only revealed only and demonstrated
recently so this for the neurophysiology
part then what we said well let's like
to do something similar if we had
computer that can access motor
information can we do any better in
recognizing actions
this again goes back 12 12 these idea of
the mirror neurons that we saw in the in
the case of the neurophysiology so what
we've done this is an experiment for a
few years back where we down here was to
record human reaching actions and build
a machine that can use motor information
only during training try to build a
better classifier and recognize these
human actions and the machine was this
one was a cyber glove couple cameras
tactile sensors for telling when we were
touching the object magnetic tracker
placed on the hand to measure the
reaching movement and what we done was
to frame this recognition in a Bayesian
framework where we had a set of gestures
there was our grass types they wanted to
recognize a set of surf features and
I'll be going back to those later and a
set of objects and we can basically
build priors in terms of the probability
that you apply certain gesture given
that you see a certain objects and this
goes back to the canonical neurosci
showed earlier that is you see the
object you recognize the object you know
what likely or what grasping actions you
can apply and we recorded the same
reaching from various viewpoints and
this was to test also viewpoint
invariant in the recognition system well
as yeah the features now the problem for
building the classifiers of course
finding features from these images of
the reaching actions we try to cut two
things basically one was go straight and
used vision and try to build a
classifier envision and we didn't want
to put much let's say priors on the
features we were selecting so we use PCA
we basically segmented the hand
normalize and did PCA and the resulting
images and and then kept certain numbers
of principal components and the other
version of these is is the following we
take vision we do the same visual
extraction but then we do a
pre-processing before doing the
classification this processing was done
by standard neural network in that case
this pre-processing takes into account
motor information so that's available
while training so what we done was to
use the FV there and the FM to build a
mapping from what you see in to the
joint angles that were recorded with the
data data glove and and then we built
the classifier in dec in this case we
skip this so this is the type of images
we collected the where hundreds of these
sequences and the word roughly 30 35
frames in each sequence prior to the
grasping of the object and as I said we
knew just by counting which was the most
likely action given a certain object use
that as a prior we built the mapping
using this neural network and yeah that
we did a classification and what what is
important to see here is that look at
this last two columns experiment three
and four that's exactly visual
experiment we're only visual features
are used and motor experiment we're also
motor motor information is take into
account now what what happens is as you
train the system no problem you do
ninety-seven ninety-eight percent in
recognition on the train set of course
as you go to testing what happens is
that if you have visual features alone
apparently the classifier as much
doesn't match harder life in in trying
to generalize and so recognition rate
goes down to eighty percent while
in the case where motor information was
taken into account during training it
seems to generalize better and
performance stays fairly high so since
there's something to be gained by doing
this pre-processing and using that into
the recognition I so later a paper by
Hinton that was doing something similar
for the character recognition so using a
model of how the person will actually
write the characters into the
recognition so effectively take into
account motor information and ice also
recently a couple people doing similar
things in speech that is pre processing
data when neural networks are trying to
get features that work better in for the
classification case and i'll get to that
on some additional neurophysiology first
this is a very recent experiment 2009
again by the group of fadiga who was one
of the students of rit so lucky these
people have been again doing TMS and
this I think is very important paper
they would be recognized to be for that
I guess in the future because it's the
first paper showing direct causal link
between stimulation in the motor cortex
and perception of given phoneme so
situation was similar to the one I
described before personal sitting and
listening but now the stimulation site
was different was in the primary motor
cortex and what they've done was
basically to go and look for so there's
a the primary motor cortex to find the
soma total p which means that there are
regions that control the particular
effector so they went and found the
region that controls the tongue and the
region that controls the lips and then
they presented people with phonemes and
made any noise these phonemes are
phonemes that are either liddell they're
required the movement of the lips or
dental that required the movement of the
tongue
okay so there are things like B and P or
T and D ok and what they done was to
basically stimulate it let's say the
tongue part while presenting either
lobule phonemes or dental phonemes and
vice versa stimulated in the lips apart
while presenting either lobular dental
phonemes and the fact that you have
noise makes everything very difficult
otherwise I will be impossible to see
the effect because in normal conditions
you perceive very well and so this
doesn't show up anyway they the results
are the following these are two measures
two different measures of performances
doesn't matter which one you you choose
let's consider the one on top is
reaction times so you asked to you as to
to tell which phonemes has been
presented while the TMS is delivered and
what happens is that the performance
increases in the case the tongue part of
the cortex is stimulated and the phoneme
is it is dental one so performance or
increase so reaction time lower in the
case you have a dental phoneme and the
stimulation isn't don't part and vice
versa if you stimulate the lips region
oops if you stimulate the lips region
the performance goes worse so and this
happens exactly the opposite if you're
presented with the lobby of funny and
you stimulate either the tongue part or
the lips part this double dissociation
means that you if you stimulate a
particular region the tank region let's
say you
effectively disturbing or improving the
recognition of phoneme that requires the
movement of the tongue so it means that
perception requires your motor cortex
one way or another perception of speech
requires your motor cortex that is kind
of again surprising at least to the
traditional view that you just
recognizing speech you just sit there
get the information and do the audio
processing and that's it so we try to do
the same on the machine and this time
its bit trickier than recording grasping
because you have to record the movement
of whatever it on the your lips
everything that is connected speech but
but the we basically replicated the same
experiment we took speech of a certain
number four names be PDT exactly the
ones that we use for the TMS experiment
and we try to collect motor information
about these phonemes and I'll show you
how we done this with this nice machine
there is a magnetic tracker so we
replace coils in the tongue of certain
number of lucky subjects and also
recorded the face with a camera we had a
few they wearing glasses glasses of
calibration and we also have an
ultrasound machine placed here just to
make it more convenient to you know
beside the coils on the time they have
to stay like this unfortunately and the
ultrasound is imagine imagine the back
part of the of the tongue we also have a
video face and also the is called larry
gorg rafi vocal folds is another machine
that you place just here and the course
the activation of the vocal folds so we
took this data are from nine speakers
and set of 74 words and syllables and I
don't remember how many repetitions so
it's few
for each phoneme I think we have less
than a thousand repetitions definitely
so it's not it's not a big train
training set definitely much smaller
than what you use for training HMMs and
then we tried sorts of bass experiment
that is the following we take all the
features and we take motor features and
motor features here for as our movement
or the tongue and in particular we took
the distance between the lips that is of
course connected with the movement of
your lips and the especially active when
you when pronouncing lobule phonemes and
and we took also the distance of the
tank from the from the feet which is
again also an indication or a
measurement of the activation of the
tongue or while pronouncing things like
te and D what you see here is a set
different set of experiments with
different type of cross-validation the
what is in nice to see is basically the
following so here we took data from five
people and tested on another person that
was never heard before so and you see if
you use only audio features you do
nicely if you do also use motor
information you do better if you combine
the two you do even better so it seems
that motor information as as something
to give of course this is the original
motor information so it's not surprising
that if you add more information than
you you do better in classification but
also we want to test things like these
where there's only one person used for
training and five people 44 in
recognition and cross validation what
what I like of these is this exactly a
situation of a person by learning to
speak because it's listening to other
people but it can it can only
have motor information of its own
movement not of the other people
movements so again combination of audio
and motor does does a better job and and
then we wanted to try something that is
very difficult for the machine that is a
cortical asian kurta collection is the
phenomenon but which you because of the
following vowel you change the way you
pronounce the concert under comes
earlier and in these again is a disaster
almost a chance level for the audio
feature salon and works nicely for motor
information the combination of the two
is worse not it doesn't improve because
I guess this is almost a chance level
and there's no way I mean it's not a
weighted average is just a combination
of the two which probably have to look
at the reliability of the signals before
combining them of course these making
confusing the machine in the same now
what were these data so the the audio
features were sort of standard Mel bang
bang spectrogram speech for a period of
two hundred ten milliseconds gives a
feature vector of two hundred donations
and the outer space is point by point
trajectories of the tongue and the lips
and desire these two numbers two
functions a velocity of the lips vli
acceleration of the lips aali and the
velocity and acceleration the tongue
tongue tip so this is the motor
information we using together with the
activation of the vocal folds that's a
binary signal 01 basically and we use
supper vector for progression Gaussian
kernel cross-validation grid search to
optimize the parameters and as I say the
cross-validation was done either overall
utterances or per speaker and the pair
speaker can be done in various ways this
summer
also the progression so the blue lines
are are the original data and the red
line is the approximation by the support
vector machine the given the fact that
starting from space that is 200
dimensional is doing I think quite a
good job in in building an approximation
there are glitches hand there we
evaluated the quality of these
approximation by looking at the
basically at the cross correlation of
these two signals and what you see is
that when you try to approximate lips
movements and the phoneme that is being
pronounced as dental for name you do you
don't do a good job in which is a game
for our neurophysiological leagues seems
to be for granted but for us I think was
a nice results showing that there are
motor outputs you don't control when you
have to so if you pronouncing something
that requires the activation of the
tongue you have less control on the
movement of the lips and vice versa so
you control only the degrees of freedom
that are required for achieving the goal
and the others are redundant and they
kind of lose and if I the they're not
approximated well when we look at the
data they're more difficult to
approximate because they there's a lot
of variability just in by the fact that
they're not controlled their match okay
this is the same same similar similar
experiment now so what we have so far we
approximated the with taking the audio
signals and mapped into the motor
information and now we try to do the
recognition using this water information
and see whether we have an improvement
by the combination of audio and motor
information now the motor information
has been the real one has been thrown
away and is just reconstructed from the
audio information there's no magic here
the only thing is that motor in first
mention is helping finding features that
are good for classification this the
underlying idea and what happens here is
that again as before so this is the
earlier plot of course with the
approximation that are I mean the
overall performance goes down a bit but
sorry but still you see that there are
advantages and disadvantages are
particularly good when in situations
where is getting things are getting
difficult so like here and especially in
the cortical asian case you know this is
much better than the chance level that
we're getting here almost translate so
yep yep yep the motor is only
reconstructed yeah exactly it's only in
the feature in fact yeah so we now go
ahead with this experiment is not
entirely finished we started looking at
the performance of the audio feature and
see when are having motor informations
really advantages I have to tell the
entire truth about these we tried hmm on
this data and they do very good they are
doing very nice job in recognizing these
phonemes but that's not the point for us
what we're looking at is situations
where there are difficulties for the
HMMs we like to have like this
additional thing the seats next to the
hmm maybe and the text when there are
situations where things can be improved
in these situations maybe when there's
noise this is all your features in
performance in classification as you add
noise to the utterances and you see that
it's easy to get to go down quickly as
soon as you add noise like fifteen
percent of the overall utterance
standard deviation of noise will give
you already a drop from 95 to seventy
percent in recognition
so what are we doing here so it's
working with the same data we had before
but now on the in the noisy situation
and in the noisy situation you still
what you see there is very nice is that
in the paper articulation case you get
very nice performance of the of the
motor features while the audio drops
dramatically almost to chance level so
it seems that these features are really
effective in difficult situations where
you may have noise on another other
disturbances between quotes like the
cortical asian case okay I think this is
it for type of work we're trying to do
just wanted to show you that these goes
into this idea of doing or doing
robotics and so in the last part of my
presentation and get into the details of
the robot oh by the way these guys
Galileo Galilei was Italian they went
all the way to build a telescope because
we wanted to do science we also want to
do science and our telescope in this
case is this one that is a human and
robot and this is the the one we develop
as part of our project so this was
developed from scratch it's all
custom-made was also built in multiple
copies and I'll show you some some of
these things since we were interested in
the manipulation we made hands so
differently from many of the Japanese
human robots we have dexterous hands we
spent a lot of time in adding degrees of
freedom to these hands for doing things
like fine manipulation dexterity and we
also have a moving head moving eyes and
this is again something that you don't
find quite often in the in the typical
of the shelf robots assuming you can buy
off the shelf profits that is fine
on and what else so this is the quick
summary of the feature so the robot is
full human or robot the size of roughly
as training half year old child so it's
a meter tall 53 degrees of freedom so
there are 53 motors inside and as I said
is designed for manipulation it should
be also able to crawl on all fours and
sit and potentially if somebody writes
the software also crawled then sit and
manipulate objects crawl again fetch an
object and so forth and the robot is
open-source are the the entire thing
including the hardware and so hardware
drawings documentation etc this is just
a video showing the showing the movement
of the fingers you see you can move the
time independently there are three
degrees of freedom in the time so you
can rotate can move the proximal joint
but also the distal once independently
the same for first two fingers and the
last two fingers are simplified there
only a single degree of freedom used for
supporting grasping you can potentially
also walk on on on two legs so it's fast
and strong enough for for walking but we
don't have the software so I mean a lot
to be done in that direction it has
absolute position encoders cameras
standard vga resolution 30 frames per
second it has microphones two
microphones and also we designed the
peanut to help sound localization so we
have this life as a symmetry but also
the shape of the outer ear is made in
such a way that changes the frequency
response as a function of elevation of
the sound something that is very
human-like we have gyroscopes and linear
accelerometers so they're mountain and
head they can be used for balance but
also for stabilizing the images such as
the robot moves as i said we designed
the entire platform so
the mechanics but also the electronics
so it's made on C programmable little
DSP boards they can communicate via
sorry by your canvas and we also design
all bunch of other electronic sports
that are required for reading sensors
and sending them to central unit which
is a pension that is mounted on the head
of course this is not enough for
computation on means standard dual core
but we have a Gigabit Ethernet the goes
outside and we have a cluster sitting
next room for computation for the real
thing so the robot is not fully
autonomous is tattered both for
computation but also for power and I
mean by the way the reason for building
these boards is that we needed to fit
them to the size of the robot so we took
particular care in making them exactly
fit the shape of the robot we couldn't
find anything of off-the-shelf in this
case given the power and all these
constraints we also design phase this
was designed later after the initial
sketch of the mechanic and that point
were kind of sick of the degree freedom
that were already too many so went for
LEDs for animating the eyebrows and
mouth so a very simple solution so
there's an array of LEDs and there's a
spreader that makes them look like
eyebrows and you can move them different
configurations and just like the outer
shell of the robot ninjas like what it
looks like when it's finished as I say
that there's no software for balancing
so that the robots being held in place
by right stand by the way since the
project as I say was up his source I
mean it's easy to say to just stick a
label and say it's open source let's see
the European Commission here wanted to
take some additional actions so they say
well build many and give to others and
that's what we've done so
at the end of the project would have a
team working platforms at the end of the
project is spring well it's January the
robots will be probably all finished by
spring next year 13 of them already
built and I've been given two different
research institutes across Europe so
like four of them under construction
like when it's finished two more under
testing and there are piecing bits on
the tables there does not quite there as
I said the in terms of making these
really used by other people this is a
list of we launched an open call and ask
people to you know proposed what they
like to do with these robots and then we
awarded seven of them to these
institutes and Paris London Leon Munich
Ankara Barcelona there's one in the
States urbana-champaign in Lisbon and we
have 18 epfl in design and then I mean I
guess because people like the this whole
idea of sharing a platform there are
more European projects that are asking
for these robots we built for for
another project called I talk where
they're looking at grinding language via
interaction and to another one that is
called an clever we're going to build
three robots now we're starting now
basically for that set there's another
project that is looking at the skin and
I'll show you some results in that
direction and we have also just kind of
random in a sense collaboration so like
with the University of course where we
develop a set of legs there is be longer
than 10 hours because they wanted to
investigate manipulation with a robot
that is able to reach a table or
relatives be too short for that they
have a more natural sort of adult size
environment we also have a simulator
very sort of very simple one
it's not meant to it's meant to help
people understand the software more than
simulating the real physics of the robot
this is about the skin this is a new
project it will make a scheme for the
entire body of the plastic you see on
top of the robot will be covered with
these sensors very easy in a sense
because it's made out of tackle
capacitive sensors these are using like
here you typically have a microchip that
is does all the job converse capacitance
into digital values and the our goal was
basically to build a deformable
capacitors so what we done we placed
electrodes on one side a silicon layer
and then a conductive layer on top so
that this is exactly like the ipod
slider if you think of it is this is
nothing different in terms of technology
the shape is different and also the
outer layer requires some thinking
because it has to protect the sensors
and also it has certain durability
issues because it gets in touch with
environment all the time and this is how
it looks like once we'll be installing
the prophet is just a test of the actual
production this is the palm again
showing that you can fit some of these
triangles showing you also another nice
thing you can cut pretty much if you
don't have the chip you can cut all the
sides and the parts of the sensors and
that's not a problem because the way
their routing the virus is done if you
don't touch anything vital like the
power supply you can cut out some of the
sensors which is like here we needed to
remove one need to remove one and we
just cut it out because was I mean we
needed to fit to the shape of the palm
of the hand we did a similar thing for
the fingertips here the technology was
bit trickier because of the size it's a
sighs you see there is 14 back to 15
millimeters in size and basically
painted the electrodes on one side and a
plastic support made a silicone mold
makes the outer layer of the fingertip
which is what you see here and then
cover at this point covering was quite
tough because we needed to get some
conductive material that was also
stretchable and moldable to this the
curvature of the fingertip and we made
in into conductive silicone I mean
wasn't difficult after we contact a
material person they could actually take
carbon black and embed carbon black into
a silicone and basically melt it and
deposit on top of the of the fingertips
and these are gives it's compatible with
the hands of the robot thing gives 12
sensing points in the fingertips so this
additional information for the robot
during manipulation let me skip this one
did what we done we also started adding
four sensors to the robot so the old
video so already we're without force
sensor so the robot is very stiff and if
encounters an obstacle we tried it tries
to destroy it if you can or destroys
itself so it's not very good we added
now to the upper part of the body so
this is under development so I'll take a
while before he gets into the robot well
we're basically changing some of the
parts sensor izing them using strain
gauges and measuring torques at the
joint level and then you can build
compliance into the system by actively
controlling the torques and we've done
these in two ways by modifying certain
parts but also by adding the sixaxis
forrester sensor are here and the upper
part of the arm so when you touch things
now you be able to sense forces and you
know interact properly this is a video
showing this joint level torque control
for one of the arms
you see initially a position control
mode which is stiff so there are as you
grab the robot by the wrist you see that
it is all very stiff very difficult to
move actually the motors are very
powerful but you can on the fly change
to a low impedance control mode this is
just zero gravity basically so the robot
will stay there and help it gives the
impression because it's something you
really have to feel rather faint to see
on video in this case but it yeah I
think it works nicely and this gives the
possibility of full force interaction
with the robot together with the skin
the two things complement each other
should be able to interact also more
safely with people and last but not
least we also develop our own software
infrastructure for the robot for
managing the cluster this is a bit like
what what it looks like internally both
in hardware and software you have a set
of DSPs with the low level controller
this PC 104 pentium inside the head is
gigabit ethernet and a cluster outside
and we have our plan being that has
particular name called yard and where
the resource of facilitates building the
cognitive high level cognitive
architecture by sending information here
not we don't have the plans but
certainly possible reserves direction so
far for us was much easier just to go
for cluster and concentrate only on the
algorithms actually not even on the
algorithm so far construction of the
problem and this is a set of videos of
showing experiments we run with bunch of
people we picture dominating Leon we're
doing some robots interaction using
speech so here the reaching grasping is
all pre-programmed by the interaction
with speeches it has been implemented
for real and what the robot does is is
helping a person in doing certain task
but also remembering sequences of
actions after a while so if you know of
this peach interaction is speed like
these you tell the rubble to grasp and
the robots says did you say grasp and
then you continue like that the relic
asks for confirmation all the time
because it's never guaranteed to have
understood correctly but if you embed
this in a sequence where and the robot
recognizes then from the initial part of
the sequence that are you doing the same
action again and again then a pre and to
you and does a voice or skips these are
all these asking for confirmation but
also certain points he says I know what
to do and starts doing the action itself
because I mean it's it's always the same
basically so trying to go in that
direction and well of course if we need
to improve the perceptual side at this
point and these are the experiment that
Robert is ramming in is using settle
neural oscillators to drive all joints
and synchronize them and this has been
done together with a group ldp FL I mean
the drumming per se is not a task they
really want to get involved into but it
is there because the same controller can
be reused for locomotion so the idea
we have have another video later this
shows the robot crawling and it's using
the same controller there but this is
much safer than crawling so for us was a
good test to start with the drumming
thing there you see well it's it's a
video that I like because was put
together in 10 days out of one of our
summer schools where a group of students
working on visual survey so detecting a
bowl in the particular case using a
particle filter and doing reverse
kinematics that are required to grasp
the ball and this one down here shows up
it's nice although the you know the
underlying system is just a plain
attention system based on the ET and
coke model so it's running vision doing
set of filtering and getting potentially
interesting locations and then driving
the eyes to look at the locations it
does a bunch of variance with respect to
the original model that is taking into
account the fact that you're moving the
head and the body so it's not static as
the the one proposed by ET then I have
two videos here shall we one there is
showing crawling is a very first
experiment and crawling up and you see
moves slowly but the robert is in fact
sustaining the entire weight of the body
i mean the the snow the bar sees here
are for attaching it to the to safety
safety little crane but and there's no
vision is fully open loops so after
while the robots get gets a stray it has
to be lifted and sorry is 24 kilograms
and what you see there is just some
reaching behavior this time be better
than what i've been done at summer
school in just shows that robot can
track an object the object is very
simple again so much vision there and
then can do the reaching
and it takes into account a bunch of so
it's interesting a process just inverse
kinematics but it's taking into account
affected the army is redundant it has
seven degrees of freedom so it gets
nicely with dealing with the position of
the elbow and takes also into account
join limits movements and other things
so we use an optimization method that
guarantees it gives certain guarantees
and I think I'm done apart from the
conclusions so what I've been talking
about is a particular view on cognition
that is what we trying to follow there
is internal models and some of them
deeply connected to the motor system as
it seems to be happening in the brain
may be advantages to copy the solution
artificial systems and this world we try
to show which is two experiments one on
recognition of grasping the other one is
the recognition of phonemes and in these
artificial systems eventually may
require a body to generate sensory motor
patterns autonomously and learning by
interaction with the environment and
this will be trying to do with robots so
giving the system a full-fledged body
and that's it thank you so video robot
well for emotion I guess you guys mostly
I doing the inverse kinematics and
emotionless mechanical wonder if you
have any plan so it's typically when
humans do things because there's so many
redundant degree films so the humans
that comes despite think of what the
part is you minimize the amount of
energy takes to come to task so there is
any motion tends to be more agile grace
yep so under it for nobody should do
same thing right so instead of just
doing the schematics on the deepest
dynamics yeah we have she activities in
that direction but that sort of ready
yet to be used on the robot there's in
particular we using something that is
called passive motion paradigm maybe the
word doesn't tell you much better
basically it's it's a method that seems
to be well in agreement with certain
behaviors and human trajectory
generation and we're looking at that as
a way I mean it has certain biological
plausibility and we're looking at that
as a way to generate motion in the robot
and also to use all the redundancy like
also move the body for reaching I mean
this point he wasn't there yet but that
is going to happen a certain point so
it's definitely I mean it's an important
talk
I was wondering so all the research that
you present it seems to be on the
software layer as far as cognition goes
are there any is there any investigation
going on that that goes into how
hardware might change to model cognition
we have a group a small group for now
people just working on a something
called neuromorphic engineering I don't
know if you heard the word it's
basically simulating VLSI chips the
behavior neurons this particular way of
using the transistors that are allowed
to build very easily neurons that have
behaviors with spiking behaviors and you
can build networks of these neurons and
in particular we're looking at building
a sensor there so that there's been
experiments already in building cameras
that work very closely to the human
retina but for instance they don't
naturally provide intensity but rather
they provide changes in intensity and
which is what what the retina does all
the time and also we're looking at
making the resolution of the sensor more
closer to the human retina lots of
pixels in the fovea and and then
degrading resolution in the periphery
and these are entails a different so
it's a different paradigm also income
between quotes in computation in the
sense that you get these spikes these
events and you have to process them
there's no frame rate for instance you
get this information all the time it's
an analog spikes and so the processing
on these cameras that had to be has to
be done differently just quite lively
community working on that around the
world and they've been doing things like
optic flow
and stereo so it seems to that will go
more in the direction of changing the
hardware radically and by the way these
chips are very power efficient which may
also count in the future if you want to
increase or put a lot to them in the
head or the robot for real so I read an
article about the software module called
a perceptron which tries to model a
neuron you know the axon and the
dendrites and all that stuff and the
idea is to have a whole bunch of those
networking and to be able to learn
without the need for a huge
computational support system like the
cost that you refer to is that something
you're aware of are there any plans to
use that in the future yeah the the
point here is that the perception is
that it is very efficient from the point
of view of the learning argument because
it's very simple and it's incremental
but it's not very good in it depends on
how you do that but it's not typically
very good indeed in the performance the
machines were using are not particularly
time-consuming in the learning stage
what the cluster is used for it's mostly
for vision at this point so the sold the
visual processing is taking a lot of
computation power and the learning you
can basically even think of using a
single computer and just leave it there
processing the data for a couple of days
and that you have a your lemon stuff you
just plug it back on the under profit I
mean it's not what we're doing but it
but it's terrifically possible it's not
necessarily the learning there is taking
most of the time depending on the size
of the problem of course
ok